all right I'm gonna enter this Terror
style get ready for it citizens of the
reject Nation we are here today I'm I'm
Greg Al say say your name on cam what's
your name he's trying to play me right
now and I can see right through it I'm
Tara Ericson you're terara ericon oh we
are watching Haunted Mansion
today oh my God I I love Haunted Mansion
at Disneyland I go on that ride I left
to get spooky season do you like do you
like Haunted Mansion Terra this is not a
bad impression of me yes I love that
ride and I should have worn my haunted
mansion t-shirt you guys know how I feel
about Disneyland I'm an annual
passholder oh annual passholders are
great okay you guys know what to do okay
leave a like leave a like that's the
first thing you got to do say something
nice in the comments for us afterwards
and also don't forget to ring the
bell ring the bell I thought it was
going to be Harmony it wasn't go it
wasn't Harmony Greg do an intro like
terara and don't forget super sexy reges
you could be super sexy too if you just
go to our patreon page that's where you
get the full length Reaction watch
that's where you sink you sink you sink
up with your own copy of of haunted
match we watching this on Disney plus
you have Disney you get Disney plus we
get we all get Disney plus so sink up
with us watch along with us all right
are you ready to do this Terra this is
that was good five stars all right let's
let's do
this welcome foolish Mortals
cool to New Orleans a most paranormal
place where death is not an ending But A
New Beginning Amen to that grief can be
a doorway to Joy if one is willing to
walk through it grief can also be a
doorway to getting attention don't
forget guys that's true P.S my mom died
cool that was a attention thing oh I
feel terrible for you yeah thanks you
can have
more
then you won't have any that's fine not
drinking much maybe we could share it
yeah make him drink first just for
safety what is it that you do um I'm an
astrophysicist
[Music]
boring I'm currently working on a
formula to map Dark Matter by combining
the structures we already have in place
with the what we're learning from Quant
mechanics and she's already sleep inside
buddy trying to see the Unseen o i
you're seeing ghosts get it girl I kind
of do the same thing I give ghost tours
oh so you don't do the same thing at all
not all when science and Supernatural
meat she does the cooler thing
Alysa
Ben
[Music]
Ben Ben oh my God I think I know what
happened I think she died and he's
trying to going to try to connect with
her here that's Jo Koy Filipino poo
Pride are you still leading her tour
look I can sneak you out the b Oh
They'll follow me so it looks like we
have a John paluso president been an
accountant for almost 50 years oh I
don't
care I've been in every haunted house in
the most haunted city in the world I've
even been in that building 72 hours you
want to know what I found nada nothing
not a thing ghost don't exist life is
dirt we're all
dirt oh homeboy broken I think you were
right cuz the bartend said why are you
still leading her tour so I think you
might have been right that she is no
longer with us maybe this is how he'll
become a Believer through by the end of
this that ghosts are
[Music]
real it's right I remember I remember
her and ow Wilson was in
this Danny deito damn the castle is in
this this
awesome Rosario Dawson it's a Loki and
Ahsoka crossover hello Jam Le Curtis
Curtis what is this cast
hey it's the movers yeah we're here how
close are you I actually even like the
way the credits are done with The
Apparition appearing like ghost credits
yeah wa cool pull
Focus that feels exactly like what
happens on the ride did you see that
thing in the mirror I sure
did wow you want to pick out your
room this kid's great
upstairs love it
no cool that looks like a mouth that
looks like a an open mouth that bed is
awesome it's Sally The Bride not
today I think Sally's from uh remember
Before Christmas oh yeah maybe well
there's a what is her name the bride and
the haunted man and I forget her name
right now but she's the one at the
end that's a fun play on like Go sheet
yeah
oh she's
gone cool
awesome
cool w
that looks
awesome pumpkin what's wrong this place
is
haunted I love this kid hey I'm going to
light a vanilla candle and it's going to
be a game changer will it though oh my
God's this kid he's funny so
good no we're
out
oh what a great transition shot there to
follow behind tracking that way safy
first slow slow you got this you got
this oh my God are the graveyard guys a
that's like the ride we they're in the
buggy I feel like I'm just going to keep
screaming that's like the
ride you'll be
back yes oh it's even keeping that
Spirit of like a period piece that is
awwesome love it I hope it maintains
this Vibe no the treasures I seek are in
heaven what kind of psychopath just
enter someone's house huh I'm sorry a
trusting white man father km by the way
you want to be a
hero pass you ready to have your mind
blown goodbye two words spectral
photography interesting gets to his
Science Background there's no such thing
as ghosts then what's the harm in just
you drive an hour north you snap a few
pics with the Ghost Camera am not
driving an hour anywhere to
hey yeah $2,000 there we are whoa my job
is having faith I got faith in you I
don't know he seems like a fraud huh
yeah he's got an ulterior motive
[Music]
maybe the Ghost Camera you know how you
and I are so different but when we come
together it's really good agreed well
this is like a bridge from what you do
to what I do right so look I got this
clever clever
man it's a lens oh never mind I thought
he was misleading her Quantum lens which
if everything works how it's supposed to
it'll change our
lives what happened you think she died
on a hunt never snapped a picture of a
ghost and she died of a broken
heart of course dead battery oh come on
you didn't charge that battery prior you
can leave oh no no no yeah you should
leave if you want to leave you can leave
it's fine Gabby I'm not afraid of a
couple ghosts you say that now why why'd
you return yeah once you come inside
like that's it there is no no going back
I guess it's just a risk I'm willing to
take now about the money uh well cuz
there's no going back maybe somehow she
was all right
damn you did not have to give me this
much money I mean I don't even know if I
can take this no take it I insist okay
okay I'm taking
it that was great
hey come on Ben you got to feel some of
that energy okay well that's my
son ah the haunted heads in the back I
love them yeah well um his father died
oh oh hey pumpkin um hey buddy do you
want to come out and and meet Mr Maas
Ben this could be your new family maybe
we start in the dining room with the
photos
H oh oh my God it's a physical
representation of the favorite room I
love looking down on that
room I love it checked in here for go
touch him don't touch him nothing you
take a photo photo
right what I'm here for the dead
battery
ah normally it will turn its head and
follow you it's absolutely terrifying it
is I mean I'm
frazzled I love how he's actually making
this sound with his
mouth sometimes he's changing it every
sharp pain on both of my sides and I
Walk This Way o cool
framing okay
that's fun how it just switched into
like handheld when it was moving
her oh there going to be a fun history
here there are some great shots in this
movie mhm I love the lighting too
everything has like a sense of blue in
there did you not notice that man come
on buddy that was a ghost in the buggy
you got did he take a ghost back with
him maybe they travel oh maybe that's
why the uh they actually ended up back
in the house cuz it takes you back
somehow not done blowing here so we're
going to get
started oh is it the one from the
painting The Fisherman one
oh as we'll find out these orbs
supposedly all
right she said once you come in you
can't go back
okay now we get the battery
going I love his performance it's really
[Music]
engaging that's awesome it
worked oh that's the
lady oh
oh
yeah oh it is SE guy
awesome
oh
whoa this really feels like a great
movie for like familyfriendly horror
yeah that was an awesome
[Music]
shot what is happening like
F what are you following me oh maybe
these Spirits need
help damn
whoa oh that's why oh does it just take
him all the way back I think that forces
you to return yeah right on
time it's a cruel trick lady they forced
us to come back here much like you what
would you could have done it spoken to
me like an adult and told me that I
could never go home again oh no but you
wouldn't have believed she did warn you
come in you can't go back it's not like
you would have believed her right you
need an
exorcist we tried that same thing
happened to
me oh my God Ben
welcome we're going to fight whether we
like it or not I feel like sometimes
you're focusing a little on the negative
yeah uh cuz we're never going to go home
again see that's a downer AR kept
wanting us to
return yeah they want to be released if
they want us here I'm going to find out
why you're not supposed to leave after
midnight you're breaking the rules stop
dude he's a rule breaker your
stubbornness is going to get you
hurt just like the ride sorry
we have become Leonard DiCaprio from
Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood take
it did I frighten you he's going to be
so excited you're here he loves yes whoa
oh my God are are you okay we're going
to need more help yeah you need to get
more souls trapped here first thing we
need to do is figure out what happened
in this house there's a professor at T
Lane who wrote a book on haunted
mansions in Louisiana only sold about
nine copies but hey he's not dead D Vito
yes well we're going to need someone who
can talk to these ghosts psychic she's
been doing readings at bar mitzz but
gets a very solid Yelp
score oh no way ah have you recently met
someone named Gary you're very good that
no I did know a cousin Gary in my
neighborhood thank you have you met
someone named
Gabby she was just deciphering all right
got to be home before God those boys
chasing oh they were just running me
home they were just running me home so
great yeah I try to get a read on the
ghost but it's hard because they just
won't stop moving they're not just
moving I I know this feeling they're
running from something yeah exactly oh
they have an enemy in their midst and
they need help the ghosts are also
trapped in there with something mevolent
William Gracie he purchased it from a
previously undisclosed owner his wife
died of yellow fever that's when things
started to get weird isn't this great I
mean I've been dying a okay I got to see
this I'm having heart surgery next week
you you cannot go need to
come I've got a car do not come then I
guess you don't need these all right oh
my God you my prediction Danny deito
will die and become a ghost of the house
R what okay start the
car hey help help so
strong ah a group of mediums went into
the house they were all found how old
are you nine okay I'm talking organs on
on the outside n is Young nine is Young
they were a group of amateurs I am a
professional certified and I can get rid
of what died oh nicely said
bye-bye ni meeting you oh she might be
fine cuz she didn't you didn't tell me
that these ghosts be following
people now I've decided to be the bigger
person and help you mostly because you
have left me no other
options so tell me what happened in this
house there's a strange energy to some
of the Rhythm in the dialogue though
these papers say what happened in this
house Wier Gracie lost his mind and took
his own life sooth by poison Two
Brothers shot each other in a
duel those paintings were wife chopped
up five of her husbands wow Constance is
her name what was the medium's name
Madam leoto I think letter from William
Gracie to Madam leoto asking her to come
to his is Seance room but we don't have
a seance room you sure wait that's the
girl in the crystal ball right nothing
here it's hold
it I got it is it a secret
doorway fun play on that trip
there
oh
[Music]
cool damn good
eye
okay whoa
neat cool it's fun that it does feel
like a Disney set in like a very
complimentary way yeah maybe I'll just
do a little blessing of prayer to get us
started on the right foot God give us a
break break
we that little music Cube felt very
Disney
like she sleep look no no no she's she's
in a trans it's a
s wait is sheep is
sheep do this
awesome he's with
us talk
to Constance who's it going to say talk
to Leota
Le can you contact someone for me oh
here just waiting for
it my wife
you were The Grieving Spirit there's a
lot of really good symmetry in a lot of
these things oh we did actually propose
there yeah I can't I don't think she's
here what good are
you
uhoh oh that's an angry ghost what does
this feel like
Madness that's the ghost I would be just
a mad this one no oh no Madam
Le
Madam oh it's like the Haunted Mansion
the ride
yeah that's awesome I didn't even
realize what they were doing so smart
yeah what who or is she at least being
let free but
why cuz she's a threat
who is that
that D yeah ah I love
[Music]
it feel my Stu I will see this house and
nothing's going to stop
me out he
goes whoa is he going further
yeah what
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm curious why a man his age was riding
a
chair likes to ride chairs yeah it's his
thing I don't like the chair
okay okay and no more excitement for
next time at my is that what that's
awesome
know I mean they can't leave him he's
haunted now all right and the place
where they overlap most is where the
living can encounter the dead through
hauntings but when a soul passes and
goes over into the region Beyond if it's
at peace that's where it staying so it
is a good thing I will randomly hear a
train off in a
distance and I know that's my dad saying
hi a so sweet that's a pleasant sign I
like what hadish gets in sinere that was
a nice tender scene I love it I just
feel I know you
already you see we have a friend in
common who is that voice don't fall for
a
[Music]
man awesome I wouldn't go in
there yes take us with you we we know
you're heading that way
soon
Alissa
makeup
Alissa whoa Bruce disappeared and
something's
happening all right going
after like the fun traditional haunting
stuff uh
hello
that's a painting from the ride I know
everything is from the ride but
like cool is he going to disappear from
the painting like the
ride you called it you called it good
[Music]
catch it's a great angle they managed to
interweave all the ride stuff in a way
that feels seamless with the story yes
and it doesn't feel overly forced it
just is like yeah it actually and easy
yeah it's a clue
[Music]
man oh that was an awesome shot he Hey
Hey Hey listen I'm sure those guys
deserve what they got but baby baby
listen I call you ghost baby but me I'm
different I'm a I'm an ally to you and
always constantly having none of
that
bab property of Madame Leota do not turn
another page [__] let's go hey oh my
God this is Madame leota's personal book
of
incantations oh my God one of us had to
do don't come yes he's in the ball in
the C the ball is this worth
anything hey cool awesome oh is that jam
Lee that must be right how did you get
in there I can show you what happens but
it will cost you how much
$3
what Ty robbery fine fine sh go
ahead William Gracie lost in grief
sought me out to contact his deceased
wife wow seriously the production design
is Top Notch yeah and the costumes are a
killer it's time to respond open a
bridge to the region Beyond she sounds
just like her I love it the repea it
seances opened the floodgates of the
ghost realm hundreds of spirits
freely oh we had summoned a terrible
evil who fed on Gracie's grief he had
the power to trap these once happy souls
in this house that's like a demonic
entity oh is this where she gets trapped
inside the yeah oh trapped me in my own
crystal ball who knows how long probably
months
now yep
yep he has trapped
933 Souls but he needs 1,000 to complete
the ritual that will let him escape this
house I love how unaware she is at the
passage of time yeah it's
$3 here for months now not on our watch
we got you but what are you going to
do they're already dead you're going to
be dead I love how O Wilson becomes
progressively less more
disinterested four lack of days go Time
movie goes on a banishment but it
requires an object the spirit once
possessed once you have that
enough oh boy there's been 66 deaths in
this house he's got
9.99 and unless one of you wants to
start funeral arrangements we better get
out of here I think you're going to be
the next one that scared me actually
didn't Madam Leota say something about
needing an object they possess now there
is something very special that I can do
is quite oh my God these ghosts are
annoying pick the shells out it's
fine you make crunchy scrambled in I
mean she'd be a grieving Spirit too
because because her husband yeah you
know I thought they coming down here we
could put everything that we went
through with his father behind us you
know he could run around be a kid en Joy
but this house just won't let that
happen going to fall off that stupid
break his leg Travis hey Travis hey let
him be a kid I go talk to him okay just
don't egg him on exactly
mhm they got egg jokes a brewing in here
you mean the cooking yeah I mean in
their heart talk to my dad today he
wants me to come
visit
but I think it would make my mom feel
bad I thought the dad was dead me too I
think we just assumed the dad was dead
yeah and I guess he's Fully Alive and
still talks to his son
oh all right you got that all right all
right all right you won you won oh my
God he could be the daddy we knew that
from the top Creek open the door to your
Dien but now my spirit will enter the
ghost
real
is it him oh here we
go
yes
oh you're Lenor Gracie hey we need your
help you shouldn't be here like the
skeletal structure there
yeah
whoa warps
glitch 1 2 3 3 4 5 brother's d
a what great color schemes I like when
he is in this space it's all pink and
normally back down it's like a bluish
this dark Spirit who is he no one knows
his mortal name his power in this realm
is beyond control please you must not
let him take the last Soul or we'll all
be trapped here forever need more
information yeah also the special
effects in this have not thrown me off
at all they look really really good yeah
I know they're
amazing w
w oh hell
yeah
yes that's the guy his head goes into
the lamp for
me
wait w that was awesome transition but
you you have promise you know that life
has no meaning that we all end up in the
dir there's the head in the lamp I can
give you what you want
go oh he's going toar argain for having
the soul of his
wife oh
wa holy junk that was that was awesome
there's no
use offering is for the weak and I know
the way out damn these transitions are
great twisty turny it makes me feel like
doct Strange Land
yeah W
[Music]
awesome
whoa whoa you can get what you
want ah back to the reg that's great
that color change is awesome yeah I know
they had like amazing camera work there
and I love the way they mess with the
backgrounds the
glitchiness my my wife died in a car
accident she liked to dance she never
she couldn't dance but she liked to she
also was the world's slowest runner
she That's my kind of Runner she said
she was going to go get some uh potato
tops she liked to take her top she has
me to go with her I couldn't do it cuz I
was frustrated I had so much work and so
so many things I still had to do so I
uh so I went
off she left apparently she uh stopped
off to get some ice cream she got into a
accident and about 20 minutes later she
was gone and
that's why I put all my time and energy
dedicated to finishing the
camera yeah yeah seems like this is the
first time we talked about it look I
don't know if any of us are going to
make it out of this aive I'll tell you I
wouldn't want to be going through this
with anyone
else look at that he found friends he's
not so alone you said the image of his
face was burned into your brain yeah I
have an idea I think l stanfield's a
very unique kind of a leading actor but
a leading actor nonetheless yes what we
would like is a sketch artist while it's
still fresh in his mind tall and hunch
kind of hunched over hey man eyes far
apart close average bit uh sunken into
the recesses of his
ular sunk like a
r they sit
back his eyes were doing that and no
eyelids so they're into his skull no
eyelids what about his nose no nose you
know no no no
no is this the man who mugged
you the police station paid off alist
crunk very bad man very bad son of
cutthroat real estate Tycoon Addison oh
that's jalet cruel father who kicked
Alistair out of the house when he was
just a boy wow love this at his mother's
funeral said he needed to make him a
tougher man
this looks like an old school graphic
novel Alistair returned a wealthy Tycoon
who became famous for throwing lavish
parties with the very people who
betrayed him what a fascinating Choice
never made their way out oh that
Alistair was embroiled in a form of dark
magic that required blood sacrifice to
maintain his wealth and power it's like
jetto in real life just before the axf
Alistair vowed revenge on all from
Beyond the Grave Crump a murderer in
life I love the inclusion of actual
animation yeah fortunately for us his
old house was deemed a historical
property up a few hours North and turned
into a bed and breakfast bed and
breakfast there you go come on what's up
with the p come on let's got to go let's
got to go
it's they're doing it God they're
actually doing it that's amazing love it
here we
go they managed to find ways to really
include this [__] in a clever way
there's always my way out TR look for a
way
out oh my goodness this whole picture is
amazing that's great now hold
on that alligator is just a ghost
alligator right so real though uh-uh you
better give it I reuke
you there it is there it is those teeth
look really sharp
ining lady wow you are holding on
seamlessly looks like it's taking no
strength to hold you might want to give
that ceiling a second look one second
Travis okay getting close yeah I like
how they the ghosts speak in like in
Clues oh
finally look look it's kid oh kid hey I
go to my car for 5 minutes and then
can't get back in the house what
happened beautiful
shot
oh this movie is at its best when shit's
just going wild yes
Bruce stay with
me oh
[Music]
man not only is this a lovely bed and
breakfast but the owners Pat and Vic do
dinner theater as well wait what became
of Danny DeVito he's dead with the Ghost
with the Headless ghost there's a tour
starting in 5 minutes I want to go on a
tour at this place what is this place
this tour will take approximately 3
hours bathroom never mind I don't want
to go anymore you'll note there's no
seating in the foyer as he would have no
Mana rer go Winona Rider he had the legs
shortened and he added pillows to his
seat as to remain above everyone else so
are those his actual pillows
no you just need one thing M apparently
they found crum's body but not the head
and the suspect walked out empty-handed
so people
think the head is still here
cool go find it be fun they're going to
become Head Hunters
Captain what is the purpose of this what
do you
need maybe you help us and we'll help
you ask him where his head is no write
your message in the mirror whatever you
want us to
do
the SE the sea yes the SE we can do that
that's Owen Wilson right away done oh
they're bargaining never mind okay what
can you tell us about
[Music]
chome ah this is going to be
fun oh great a dead end yeah come on you
know better than that into the fireplace
we go I can't fit in there yeah me
neither but you know who
can come on buddy you got to go down
there you got to
go I'm glad we finally get some time
with him because I think he's hilarious
and we haven't heard from him in a
minute yeah I felt like the movie was
going to be way more about him and then
kind of I thought he was kind of a lead
right
yeah this is where he hit all the bodies
a ghost going to pop up behind one of
them there it
is oh my God
man I hope everyone's okay I would have
also grabbed the head yeah just let me
be a part of this he just wants to be
included Travis is just too dang dous
listen you made him go down that chimney
and go with all those ghosts I'll try my
dad
okay see it I feel like is his dad dead
and he's caught like no never mind I'm
not even a priest yeah everyone wants to
think their house is haunted so I go
sprinkle some holy water and get paid
I'm a
fraud I'm sorry that was the most
obvious thing in the world you helped me
seeing myself that I had something that
was useful whatever it is that we got to
face we can't face it without you let me
ask you something you want to be a hero
n nice reversal I mean the fact that you
wouldn't know that he's not a real
priest after he goes God give us a
break Bruce you got to stop doing that
possessed where is everybody the house
is clear it's over Harriet found some
mumbo jumbo in that book pay attention
to his voice God quite hary but the sh
struggle was necessary for character
growth okay so where's Harry and G uh
why are you talking like
that that's uh come on sense falseness
you are a fraud yourself I'm going to go
find them
oh and then they were two it's happy
hour somewhere right no no what a turn
of phrase
H happy
hour talk about overselling
it
Dad I'm scared dad is dead okay that's
what I was going to say right before
call his dad and like bring his dad in
the car and then I thought I would sound
dumb you have to understand guys when T
and I watch something together we're
bound to get confused by something
everyone else does not get confused by I
got you I got you I got you I got you
give me
me he is surprisingly strong for a
little
person no no what happens
now it's a full moon prump has all his
powers start the banish me okay okay
strange ADR choices in this thank you
for your assistance
Professor wa are
999 Souls that reside here but there's
always
room for one more I like the blend of
CGI and makeup Travis is okay all right
he's at the car he's talking to his dad
what that that's not possible Gabby he
still talks to his father his father is
dead Ben just over a year
I thought she'd clarify so even he was
confused oh my God okay so his dad is a
ghost yeah yeah yeah which I knew that
but I'm like why is here you have the
most important job of them all Kent you
the diversion we're running out of
time come on K I have faith in you have
faith in
[Music]
yourself damn the vision jeels really
are the star of this movie
yeah time to divert what a fun house the
only chance we have to defeat him is
combining our might you must Release Me
is it going to be a positive thing this
way with the Realms blending we can find
a faster
route oh my God it's Harry Potter Set Me
Free and I will help you banish him is
this a good thing or are we setting her
up for a villainous sequel is that
you Dad I'm
here is the dad a malevolent or
benevolent I can't tell me neither
Travis Travis all right I need you to
give me your hand I'm going to see my
dad look I made a mistake okay I was
wrong uh uh I I can hear him TR who is
that man they have to be going willingly
oh right no I I hate it here I know but
you and your mom are going to be
somewhere completely different than this
I hate it
everywhere a this poor kid all right you
come here you tell me all about your
misery we'll be miserable together till
there's nothing left trus don't you miss
me a you got it you got it don't don't
with me please come I like the messaging
of like the healing power of grief as
well for all
eternity you and I make a
deal all you have to be is
willing he has to be the Willing soul
and believe me I know a con when I see
one in fact this was all a con yeah this
whole Chase was just a diversion wow
he's Ling about everything ask yourself
are you ready to be a hero
[Music]
oh wow
all going to leave them alone you're
never going to hunt them again ooh cool
set take my hand and you will be with
your
[Music]
belov oh the horse who you imprison me
now it's time to return the favor
pathetic see to them
[Applause]
whoa they'll have to come through me
first and by me see means
we everyone has banded
together oh
no oh boy I've been convinced he's going
to die this whole movie when hinges
Creak inless
chamers wa these Souls will not be
displaced
take that it's like Ghostbusters come
with me to see your wife this is your
last chance to tell ala that you love
her she already
knew she she
knows
no that awesome
wonder what the specific EX look so cool
that was so heartfelt and sweet too like
the flashbacks with her like was now him
with reaching like death it's like he
knows she knew he loved
her like we couldn't do it without now
die Danny
deito it's like the POV is exactly like
the r and I love
it he got to the Sea's getting to the
Sea they yeah pH kept their
promise you have allowed the ghost to
commit theft oh so
pretty what's this you got says Alissa
or something
will that's way better ghost wink it's a
ghost wink and a ghost
sweet I was voted as vice president of
my class whoa you climbed the ranks of
friendship and popularity that's a
180 before you step
inside this could change the course of
your entire life that's a risk I'm
willing to
take kiss
[Music]
her
bra shot
[Music]
out
ah why did they do like you know a
walkthrough like they do for stranger
things but it should have been for this
movie like a walkthrough of the Haunted
Mansion why didn't you guys do that it
would have been a good idea oh I'm so
mad now that you okay now let's watch
Yeti Murphy
version I have not seen that I have not
seen the Eddie pery version I haven't
seen it I wonder if it's
good yeah I was just getting some New
Orleans singing in style of
singing I am not eating at all today
Tara I am so hungry me too I think we
should have a big meal and then continue
this review oh okay right after are you
going to cook the meal cuz I didn't
bring food here and I got to be here for
a while so no no you can postm yourself
something something out of your own
pocket yeah all right I just thought
maybe he'd cook me up something nope no
you know no we'll talk first we can talk
first so what' you think
Tera I loved it I thought it was really
cute I loved uh I mean I really like the
kid I wish there was more of him in it I
liked the comedy the comedy and the
pacing of the tone everybody in this
delivered on that in that regard like it
was all when it needed to be funny it
was I liked how the the lighting with
the ghosts the ghost always had a pink
uh Pink esque to them um there's a
pinkes there's a pink esque and uh the
shots kept it really really engaging but
you know what's what was not bugging me
but I was like when is that handheld POV
shot going to come back from the
beginning where we're looking at a POV
from the ghost point of view with the
people and it never did um I don't mind
that I just thought they could play with
that more um but I do like how heartfelt
and sweet it was there was great
messages in here of like especially when
he's speaking to the kid of like your
dad loves you and he wants you to see
you thrive and be happy um you know the
kid needed to let his dad go in a sense
at the same time that our lead needed to
let go of his wife right and and I guess
grieve that more and know that she knew
that he loved her right um which was
nice I think there was just and I like
that they didn't because we caught that
vibe in the beginning of him and Rosario
that they're like oh you're going to
become a nice happy family and instead
it made it all of them which I think is
way better to not sure there's a vibe
there at the end but to not show it I
like it so much
more yeah yeah damn that is a
glowing glowing review wow he called it
glowing that was that was a that was a
high praise review right there wow High
pra summation of your thoughts there
happy to hear it um some stuff kind of
fluctuates for me I'm not as a high
here as you are however I I I see this
through two different lenses here one is
the Target
demographic well there's kind of like a
couple of camps of a Target demographic
I would say there's ones who love
obsessed with the ride I I love the ride
I do I think it's like my favorite thing
the last time I went to Disneyland it
was shut down it's like it's really
common for that ride to be shut down
it's a real pain in the it's always like
stay in your
buggy I wish I knew the message I it's
shut down constantly I'm like what the
hell's going on with this ride but then
you whenever you go on it you're like
looks like there's a lot of work that
goes into keeping this ride operational
you know um but it's really and they
it's even cooler when it's Halloween
time they make it all Nightmare Before
Christmas I love that ride I really do
um I wonder what it's like in Universal
Studios or
Orlando uh Universal Disney World
Universal Disney World Universal stud
yes because the room where this the
sance with the four chairs where they
were like initially beginning I that
does not look totally like the Sans room
in Disneyland but I was because the
walls look very different and I was like
does that room is that what it looks
like in Disney World because people say
the rides are larger and longer there so
I don't know could be yeah yeah um I
often hear that about many things yeah
that it was larger and longer yeah yeah
you're not the first woman to say that
sentiment to me mhm yeah I'm sure not
I'm sure plenty have said it which is
why you settle down you're like snag it
quick CU if the word gets
out you
know gonna be let me tell you it's
really easy to have a disappointed wife
around town you know what I mean yeah so
anyway the kids movie Tera yeah well be
mindful you know that was spoken in
metaphor maybe we should watch the s
anding around here and you should know
when to reel it in a little bit all
right to call me out on my stuff uh yeah
cuz there's that side and then there's
also the main demographic which is like
the family just it's Disney and they
want to be family accessible and I think
on that on that front because I I think
like a movie like Pirates of the
Caribbean 2 is harsher in terms of this
is real perilous this is real spooky
scary like that one is like really
intense and scary and maybe not as like
family accessible Pirates 2 I'm talking
about specifically where this more so
goes to the camp of wanting to be more
into like a pirates one I would say
where you're like it's not exactly scary
but it's got some of that spooky ghost
Vibe and whatever um so in terms of like
a familyfriendly accessible Halloween
type of Adventure I I think that it's
pretty damn great I think it's really
really great in that realm because they
bring a lot of the like the set design
the art Direction just the overall
production the the makeup I thought was
great and the and there's a lot of
inventiveness and a lot of vivid
creativeness when it comes to keeping
like the dark aesthetic but having it be
it it feels like a really elevated
Disney Channel movie yeah you know what
I mean yeah like okay this is above and
beyond Disney Channel uh
but it's still it still really pops and
it's vibrant and I love theith Stanfield
a lot like for a leading character he's
very unique because he's very despondent
and he's not as like high energetic yet
he doesn't ever feel like he wants to
ever steal the show like he really cares
to share the screen and I I loved I
loved him a lot and overall that I think
the Journey of grief and acceptance is a
great thing to constantly it's kind of
in a lot of movies but I I I like how
this sort of leads with that there's
there can be a beauty and a and a
bonding nature to be found in you know
and grief yeah the the parts of it that
were kind of like flip-flopping for me
was honestly just there's something
about the there's something about the
pacing especially within the just the
the dialogue scenes themselves you
notice it mainly when When Tiffany
hadish started speaking in the house as
like getting into the next realm right
you were like her tone is weird but I
don't know if you just meant her if you
meant when it started there it got a
little off kilter I meant kind of like
with like and it wasn't so much in like
the first 20 to 30 minutes but the movie
is 2 hours and I and I think in a lot of
it there was some type of strange way
the pacing and the Rhythm was done when
it wasn't a spooky intended type of
scene when it was just them kind of
going back and forth and around the
table like there like part of the
editing would feel a little would feel
off to me and that the way those scenes
would Breathe would feel too long of a
breath I don't no I actually feel too
short I think I think there was like uh
there there was a something that felt
kind of Curt about the way a lot of
things were kind of uh done and it kind
of just get wrapped up really I'm not
not exactly sure it's sleep deprived and
really hungry but I know how I feel and
I got to get that feeling communicated
properly it's one of those challenges
that I'm doing right now it feels like
it's like quippy dialogue but it wasn't
quippy dialogue it's like they're trying
to do it in the edit yeah yeah there's
like a a lack of an energy to me that I
wasn't quite feeling because I think as
individual performers everyone is like
well C like everyone was well cast for
the roles that they got and obviously
the weight was given primarily the
substance to like Keith Stanfield and
the little boy which is arguably where
the weight of the performances really
have to go to where everyone else kind
of
felt
um you know the word is not Bland
because I think the C the actors
themselves provided a a personality for
them it was a little two-dimensional
when I think like two you know what I
mean yeah I do I feel like the scene
with Owen Wilson and the ghost at the
end had that right kind of like cuz it
was just him with their responses and
that felt more like in the realm to me I
don't know why oh really okay see that's
where I think we're differing because I
was I wasn't really clicking with with
some of that stuff and especially at the
very end in the big finale I did I did
feel that with the way the sound design
was done that a lot of it felt like they
were fixing a lot of this in post and I
didn't really feel the physicality of
the emotion in the voice the perform
perform yeah was like this weird hodge
podge stuff and just overall the the
rhythm of a lot of the scenes and maybe
it was just like the comedy itself
wasn't particularly working for me yeah
but the but the thing is I don't I like
while I don't love a lot of the scenes
and there wasn't spooky stuff
happening the thing I showed up for was
that stuff yeah and I really enjoyed
that you know so that's why I would
still give the movie at least on my end
I would still give it like a 7 to a 7.5
because the things I wanted to work
before hitting play on this really
worked for me yeah um like the homages
to the ride I thought they worked in the
the ride elements very well uh to the
point that even if you don't know the
ride it's it doesn't distract you like
like You' feel left out or some [__]
right that worked really well um all the
Aesthetics of it I like to me the real
stars of this movie was the way this the
cinematography was was done and in those
horror scenes and also just the the
visual language of pretty much all of
that I thought was really great and the
when they would they use like animation
blends to enhance other flashback stuff
but yeah it's like you got a you got an
ensemble of characters and I only really
cared about one person yeah you know
were two people and even like Rosario
Dawson as grieving wife maybe it was an
intentional thing but kind of felt like
she was just kind of like
charismatically chipper for for most of
it and like I'm a little stressed but I
didn't really feel like the weight of
her performance right you know right
yeah I didn't feel that either so that
was that was probably the part like when
you're reading the cast list in the
beginning like oh we're going to get a
real Ensemble here but for some reason a
lot of it was just feeling kind of flat
to me instead of really singing when I'm
like a you got a real Ensemble here and
I think a lot of that should have really
saying hi but like I said I think the
things that I saw Snippets of over my
shoulder when an ad was playing I I
never actually watched like a trailer
from beginning to end but the things I
saw like little bits of and uh for the
Halloween spooky season time the the
things I really I'm not just saying it
to be nice like those are the things
that really worked for me strongly yeah
and so for me I would definitely still
say I liked it and i' recommend it
because this is the kind of movie that
you can put on for the family at
Halloween time and still really enjoy
yeah totally I mean that you can play
for kids but adults also won't be like
totally bored out of their minds right I
also don't know that the movie needed to
be two hours I I'm like I I wonder if if
it was you know an hour and 30 and would
have moved faster that it if it would
have you know you know when movies can
they move quick where you're like whoa
that was great because it just felt like
it was there and then it was gone um I
don't know if that would have helped it
a little bit but
um yeah yeah I mean I I I'll give it
like I'll give it an eight out of 10
because
I is this this one 84% damn really I
mean it's got 84% audience score which
is like yeah that's great Tomato Meter
is no go but the Tomato meters 37% and I
could not be further off with that all
like I there's no way I would give it
that wow yeah what is the what is the
the idea here why everyone's only
everyone's upset about this this fil oh
it's saying it's play playing it even
safer than its 2003 representation and I
don't can't make a reference to that
um um yeah okay yeah that the that one
the rules one right I guess I don't know
I yeah I I I know what I didn't really
care for uh which was I I didn't really
feel the chemistry of The Ensemble as
much as I wanted to and I didn't really
and I thought there was some very weird
editing choices in in those scenes but I
think for a paranormal good
time I I thought it was I thought it was
really fun right I thought a lot of that
was really fun it's okay I could not be
more I had no idea the reviews were this
bad it's it's it's kind of surprising
yeah it's weird and I'm like there's one
that says they don't we don't know where
the ghosts come from and so everyone is
confused and I'm like well if you've
ridden the ride if you've been on the
ride and you know The Haunted Mansion
you kind of know where the ghosts come
from yeah so we don't need that
background sure if someone's like coming
in uh you know as a blank slate which
why have you not been to Disneyland
before and why are you watching this
movie but I'm just saying uh I wasn't
confused I mean they did explain that
that guy was stuck but whatever uh I
guess people
people really this is so I am surprised
by the negative feedback uh like like
just how negative it is you know yeah
diffuses any potential scares with a hot
color pink palette I did bring that up
um I don't think that diffused it I
think there was I think there was one
point when um he's walking up on his
wife and he goes like Alyssa he calls to
her that I'm like oh why didn't that
scare me when she turns around and
smiles and it looks creepy and I'm like
oh they had laid on that shot in silence
a little bit longer Alyssa waited waited
and then it kind of comes around but
it's like too fast where it's like yeah
they're diffusing it so it's we're not
building up all this like tension see I
that's where I feel like the movie at
times was kind of at odds with itself
too fast right like it didn't allow the
it didn't know if like we wanted it I
felt like they would actually wanted to
be more horror and wanted to be scarier
and then they had to do things things to
dial it back because they can't because
CU you can't be that scary you know but
I think the movie actually wanted to go
that far um kind of like how amlin back
in the day would have done it or even
like we just saw Monster House you know
like and even though it's an animated
movie I would still liking that to oh
it's a it's a it's a family horror movie
and that one would like they'd go there
they they do and I think this movie
wanted to go there and it wanted to have
have a little bit more of a mature
element to it as well especially when
you have our main character dealing with
the death of his wife I think the movie
was at odds with itself at times in
terms of what tone do we strike yeah I
think tonal CU like the tone was not
quite I didn't really get a sense of
like an atmosphere or a specific tone
during this during this experience yeah
you know and I think that was the part
of it that was kind of missing for me CU
where I could
feel where it could be at odds
throughout a lot of the
journey yet though I I still think I
still feel like I saw I was able to
watch this from well what audience are
they targeting and then from from being
able to sit in that seat I I was able to
really enjoy it oh yeah yeah you know
still like super super fun and I'm like
they did have the ability to make those
moments last longer and make them
scarier and more of a like ah but there
was still smaller moments that was like
oh that was spooky which was fun and
still very again family
friendly
yeah kind of like 37% is really harsh I
don't know where these people are from
or what they're doing but like like one
just says cannot be counted as anything
more than a missed opportunity but get
this he works for Pittsburgh magazine
and I'm like you probably haven't been
to Disneyland because if you have and
you've you've been on the ride there's
just so many like Easter eggs in here
and they they incorporate it so well and
I'm like do these people think that like
this is not based off of a ride yeah
like are they just like oh we're pulling
it from thin air and they could have
made a story a lot better I'm like
they're incorporating a ride that people
adore and love and there's only so much
EB and flow that you can do in regards
to story when you're also attaching it
to a ride like they did story with the
lead guy and the kid and like letting go
of grief and all of that but that
headless guy is in the in the ride
before you get like they're in there's
there's certain things they got to
follow and I feel like some of these
people are like I don't know they're not
Disneyland fans and they don't get it I
don't know and feel you on that I I
think too is in terms of how they
Incorporated that stuff from the ride
was just really great so good I think
they did it great and and um I'm I am I
am it's weird like I okay with the
criticisms about like I scroll through
some of these criticisms but I just feel
I guess I feel like just the pros
outweigh the cons for me yeah AB
absolutely I feel the cons like a lot of
the cons are about kind of the things I
was just saying like I think the P some
the pacing is a little weird yeah and
and uh yeah the performances fall like
in this weird camp where it's not like
it is the energy that can feel flat of
of certain moments but the things that
work just really shine like it was is
visually really appealing and it it
speaks to the sensibilities of things
that I personally enjoy watching um so
yeah I had fun I had fun I don't I do
not regret my experience and I could see
this being a great Halloween movie to
watch every year I think it's a really
fun movie thank yeah and I think if
you're a fan of the ride yeah it's
really enjoyable but yeah guys what did
you think about it leave your thoughts
down below be sure to subscribe leave a
like Tara thanks for helping me uh enjoy
more of this spooky Halloween season
spooky and yo homie homie will you help
me shout out someone yeah all right man
I think you will let me just make sure
your your next person isn't here all
right you're good you're good to go what
do we got what do we got Tara Tara
always says my name wrong CZ he thinks
it's funny do I I don't know sometimes I
do okay no no
nope all right we got a shout out okay
let's do it we gotta shout out Michael B
Michael B Jordan he's missing the Jordan
at the end but it's all right because I
don't even like no that's a lie I do
like Michael B Jordan but I like Michael
B too I don't know anything about you
why don't you tell me too well Michael B
has a YouTube channel called omn media
wow he does reactions he's great and I
think based off the upload schedule I
devised his video that he just shot with
John he lives in Virginia oh so he had
to film remotely wow um that he shot
with John was mission Impossible dead
reckoning oh and I think that went up
yesterday
cool so go and he did reactions to all
the mission impossible his an impossible
Tom Cruz for life baby
yeah cult yeah and uh I'm in it happy to
be he's a great guy and um he he gets
just as much sleep as me usually so we
have a lot in common I love that you
like Tom Cruz too because so do I that's
the end of my rap Michael B I don't need
to RH you rapping or were you just
saying words in a rhythm that sounded
like it was a rap both I was doing a
combo you're welcome it's easy to just
put your words in a
type is it because I find you struggling
right now I find you struggling to do it
okay hey you want a peanut butter
sandwich before you film again cuz he's
going to cook me something I'll make
I'll make you a peanut butter sandwich I
I am so
hungry I've tried hiding my Hunger but I
have like no water and no and I'm like
what did I do to myself I need to drink
more water weird time to film a 2hour
thing and be like be sharp Greg not
today not today but
honest honest Always Love You So Much
comment tell us how cool we are bye okay
[Music]
bye